[Music]
Runk hey yo I'm going to be in Brea
California coming up here January 18th
and 19th and then Phoenix Arizona
January 20th El Paso Texas Albuquerque
um New Mexico Colona BC Vancouver BC I
think Colona is almost sold out
Vancouver is sold out and we added
another show February 10th Rochester New
York kitner Ontario shreport Louisiana
Houston Corpus Christie Durham norfol
and we're announcing a lot more soon
chia.com going over there they might be
up now who knows I got to I I I um I
recorded this few days ago but uh yeah
let me know uh where you're coming and
then uh you can go check my uh new
special crystal.com go get it uh
appreciate you and uh subscribe to our
patreon here at
patreon.com christalia and uh let's get
into the next episode of
[Music]
congratulations it
is January well right now it's January
we a little behind the scenes it's we
record January 15th oh I just realized I
wore a u a sweatshirt that's amazing cuz
it's going to be too
hotat it's going to be too hot in about
3 minutes and that's amazing and and I
realized that I'm going to have to take
this off in the middle of the podcast
and then I realized my shirt's going to
be the shirt that I'm wearing under it
is an undershirt is too small but it's
okay dude maybe you'll see your boy
Juiced up you'll see me Juiced up I
don't do steroids so stop with that but
I will uh if my wife lets me so um she
doesn't want me to do it I don't do
drugs dude I'm straight up drug free I'm
drug free and I'm sucker free in 2024
that's what we are is it 2024 wow that's
crazy I don't really know the date
anymore ever since I didn't go to
school uh and that's just kind of how
it's going to be for this 43y old man um
I I I uh I did shows in uh Sacramento we
did two shows it was very fun Sacramento
came out did that that little Crest
theater there is a good theater uh
it's you know theaters are um
interesting right because either they're
uh from
1905 and they're historic and they're
beautiful and
great and what they lack in modern
modernity is that not that's not a word
but in
modern mod whatever the word is
modernness I guess Mna is the uh drug is
the
shot what it lacks in being modern is it
it makes up for in Beauty and um um you
know history I guess
okay and and then there are state-of the
art theaters that were built like since
2021 and you play those and what they
lack in character they make up for by
like well you know you can play either
3,000 or 5,000 depending on if we hit
this button or not and let the walls
open up and look at the lighting and
look at the way we have everything all
dialed in and you know the and oh and by
the way all the door frames are the
right size so you don't hit your head
cuz people were 4 feet in 1990 in 19 in
1900 people were 4 feet 1990 um and uh
and so you'll go to play some of these
theaters that are
historic uh that are are are cool and
you know look I'm all about the new [__]
always I'm always about the new [__]
like classic cars get out of here need
Bluetooth oh really oh it's a classic
car or is it just to jalap yeah oh it
looks nice oh was it made right K but it
wasn't though was it cuz we're the cup
holders right was it made nice yeah okay
but also does it have a key fob where
you can just hit the button and the
doors unlock oh it doesn't so was it
made right I get it it looks nice but
also in the way does
it
right yeah it doesn't look like it was
made on a factory line but okay but you
know so
whatever um so some of these theaters
are beautiful and they're Char and they
got a lot of character and they're great
and they're uh and then you Bonk your
heads because the doorways are too small
always do it with these old theaters by
the way they should have [__] known
in 1910 they should have known that
people were getting bigger period you
know it's not like they should have like
allowed it to be I I what what what what
really is crazy is how many doorways
built before 1950 are so small when it's
like dude you knew people were getting
bigger and you knew this was going to be
around for a while so
sup um but here I am in like a theater
in Oklahoma or whatever the [__] in
Virginia just I'm walking out with wel
some bruises on the top of my head
because the [__] doorways are too
small and yeah I'm a tall drink of water
I get it but still dude we should just
make
doorway from now on don't even make
doorways just make garage
openings you don't know how big we're
going to get before we have to all
colonize in Mars there's no doorways
there are there no no cuz they know
what's up we're going to be there and
we're going to be [__] walking around
no door there there's no doorways I mean
everything's a big doorway there in Mars
because there's no rooms
but
anyway
um then there are theaters that are the
so there are the state-of-the-art
theaters and then the nice theaters that
were built in 1910 and then there are
theaters that are like built in
191 or 20 that are like haven't been upt
and are shitty and they pretend like
they're historic venues and it's like no
just burn it down make a new
one and I'm not going to say if the
Crest theater is one of those or
not but what I am saying is historic
venues like uh the Ryman are
beautiful um so anyway but every time
you go to one of these theaters there's
that guy that's just
like yeah this is it this is when uh
this is when they brought in the uh they
had uh the original performance of
Greece here for three months and the the
town had a they thought it was too
risque so they had a protest and this is
where one of the protesters died and
you're like can I just get on stage and
tell my dick jokes dude can can I just
start talking about cargo pants into a
microphone but anyway I I seem
ungrateful I'm not I'm I'm grateful for
all the gigs I'm grateful for everybody
that wants to talk to me uh and uh and
you're allowed to have bad days and
that's it dude I I I actually when I do
the meet and greets I sell 100 tickets
for meet and greets and those go quick
by the way people are always hitting me
up I see them on the Instagram comments
and stuff like do you how come you don't
do meet and greets I do do meet and
greets but they all sell out in like a
minute when I go on sale because those
are the tickets that get sold quickest
because the people who want to do a meet
and greet are the people who buy the
tickets quick because they know what my
schedule is because they're fans of
mine
so um I do meet and greets I'll tell you
what man I meet a lot of really nice
sweet people in meet and greets some
people with bad breath you know some
people just stink straight up and some
people smell very nice some people are
so sweet and caring some people would be
my friends some people I think well
that's interesting that person likes me
I wouldn't think that person likes me or
my comedy but I'll do a meet and greet
and
um and it's nice and and sometimes I see
the pictures online that the people post
from the meet and greets and I'm like oh
[__] man I got to work on my
face CU I'm not in a bad mood sometimes
I'm not in a bad mood and then I see a
picture of me and I like and I'm like oh
I got to work on my
face because this is how I am totally
happy but this is how I
am look look this is me getting a this
is me getting a
check
thrilled don't look it I don't really
ever know what my face is doing maybe
that means I'm a bad actor I'm a good
actor though so I don't get
it
um so anyway I'm in the middle of
watching this documentary the the the
fall of Minnesota and it's just like
they're it's trying to like it's just
trying to push me further I'm in the
middle of the fall of Minneapolis or
whatever it's called fall of Minnesota
fall of Minneapolis I never know which
one's the city and which one's the state
because don't have the main city in your
state start with the first half of what
the state name starts with right
right and the worst culprit is New York
New York and then New York New York at
least in a way it's the best because you
can't really be wrong you know I'm from
New York oh New York New York New York
oh New York I meant to state but yeah
New York New York I'm from that actual
City so yeah works both ways you
wouldn't you know Minneapolis Minnesota
is
crazy it's like if there was a it's like
if Los Angeles were called uh Cal
californ
amen like California amen California or
Cal California I I get mixed up so
Minneapolis Minnesota
Minnesota anyway um I'm watching the
fall of min neapolis
and I don't want to be
pushed dude I'm like I'm like you man
I'm just a
guy with a
job I'm just a dude I'm just an
American Dad I'm a dad with two
boys lovely
wife
got property you
know cut me I bleed I hate that saying
you know that that that one was that's I
was watching a DAT line until one of the
people said you you know you cut me I
bleed I I turn out I Keith Morrison can
handle it I'm not
watching you caught her she bleeds and
um you caught her she
bleeds and
uh so I'm watching this fall in Min
Minneapolis you guys if you don't know
what what it is it's about the
uh George
Floyd um Derek shavin case or whatever
the
[__] shaven shauan sh
shoban and
uh you know there's that whole narrative
in the media where it's like you put the
they you know he had his knee on him and
he choked him and I'm like okay why
would the media lie about this if this
was the thing why would politicians lie
about this you know if this was the
thing why would they do
that and then I'm like but wait a minute
but I'm watching this thing the fall of
M Minneapolis and I'm just
like hold on a second the guy the guy
who [__] did the autopsy why were
they trying to cover cover up that
[__] fentel in his
[Music]
system great he kept fentel pills in his
mouth and cracked them
open great he wanted to hide the drugs
in his mouth and then the cop shook him
around a little bit and then they broke
and then he died from fental
[Music]
great oh
[__] and I'm like I don't want to be far
far I'm dude I'm a guy with here's the
thing and and you know I used to think
about this like does the government need
to tell us everything and I'm like no
cuz like they're not going to anyway so
who gives a [__] I got my two boys and
wife and I'm cool I'm chilling and
friends and loved ones but it's like
dude if you're going to lie that hard
about something or try and control
narrative or use someone's death to try
and you know and look I don't know the
truth I don't know that [__] thing uh
that I watched could be could they could
be lying I have no idea that's the
[__] thing dude God I hate I don't
like watching stuff anymore because it's
like you don't know what the truth
is maybe I shouldn't even be talking
about this I'm sure they'll like you
know say this is misinformation or
something I'm not which I'm saying I
don't know I'm saying I don't know I
don't
know 75% of his arteries were blocked
Jesus Christ and they're saying
[Music]
that but I'm just saying dude you know
what I mean you have prec consisting
heart condition it's just
[Music]
like I know dude they didn't release a
body cam footage until way later after
the trial I know but it's just
like I know dude but I'm just saying why
couldn't we see the body care footage
why couldn't it be admitted in the
courts why couldn't it do it why
couldn't the [__] juror see the body
Cam Body cam footage must be something
I'm just
saying all
good I know
dude I shouldn't be saying it but it's
not me I'm just I'm not even the mouth
what's a mouthpiece what do they say
when they say that I'm not the whistle
blow dude whistle Bim blow the
whistle but it's just like come on man
Jesus
anyway let's get off this [__] cuz I
don't want the conspir some conspiracies
are I don't want the nut job you know
what I mean it's
like I did go to the gym the you know
what how [__] hardcore I am this is
how I'm I'm going to tell you something
dude I'm an insecure person and that's
okay everyone has their insecurities
that's all good it's fine some days I
wake up and I think wow I'm looking
handsome some days I wake up you know
the next day I wake up and I'll think
I'm a I'm an ugly piece of [__] [__]
this right whoops hey dude I you know
get a little real but hey not hey oh
who's that oh hi realness is at the door
and I didn't I you know what I mean I'm
just chilling but I some days I wake up
I look in the mirror and I go I'm ugly
as [__] even worse than that I'll take a
shower get ready put on an outfit I'm
ugly as [__] oh [__] hello it's realness
I know and I don't want it to be right
I'd love to live in The Matrix
so many fuzzies on this [__] thing
I'd love to I'd love I'd love to live in
The Matrix but he can't when he looks in
the mirror some days he goes hello who
is it realness you're ugly oh [__]
dude how ugly am I you're just a regular
dude you're a blob of Flesh hello
realness here oh [__] hello realness
you're the color of [__] you're ba
you're you're almost translucent
translucent hey who's that hey realness
get back here oh you don't want me you
don't want me you didn't even like the
last stuff I said see you
later all right see you
realness why don't you show up when I'm
handsome you're not
[Music]
atome and so you know I'll walk
downstairs and I'll tell my wife look
I'm having an ugly day and she says
don't say that you're handsome and I go
that makes it worse dude so why do I
even bring it up hey he's just as
insecure as the next
guy
but I'm at the gym the other day and
this is how hardcore I am okay I'm at
the gym the other day and this is how
hardcore I am all
right he was also just getting over Co I
know dude but it's just like and it was
the first strain oh Jesus but I'm just
saying right you know the first train
took some people out but all I'm saying
is not me that that was about the
earlier follow Minneapolis but what I'm
saying is here's how here's how hardcore
I am okay as was at the
gym and I'm getting I'm gonna tell you
right now I'm getting I'm
getting I'm I'm getting beefy all right
yeah okay I said it all right people
they come up to me they go like this hey
what's up Chris wow dude that's what
they do and I'm not in control of what
other people do all right so I'm just
report on the mouthpiece here okay I'm
telling you what people do when they
coming to me hey Chris oh wow I didn't
know you were like this oh sh you you're
you're stacked like a [__] brick house
right brick [__] house whatever the [__]
it is I always [__] that up
but you
know yeah the shoulders go on for days
and yeah the [__] you
know I'm working out my shoulders yo
check out how hardcore I am man I don't
even want to say this
but I'm doing landmines yeah right I am
I'm doing landmines I'm taking the f
[__] weights and I'm pushing them up
and I'm pushing them up and I keep
adding weight and whoopsy Daisy right I
I do I keep doing that right I'm in the
zone dude I'm in that [__] don't let
me into my zone don't let me into my
zone don't let me into my zone I'm way
past that part of the song I'm in the
zone song's almost
over and
uh I'm doing it you know pushing it up
at the
landmine boom pull my
back how hard Chris so
hard how much does it hurt it's
painful so I go huh I got I put it down
I go hm you know when you pull your back
so hard you're doing something and
there's people around and you're like I
don't want to look like a [__] but also
who gives a [__] you know cuz I'm like
ah today I woke up and I felt handsome
but tomorrow I might wake up and be a
fat blob of
[Laughter]
[__] so I put the weight down and I go
like
this maybe because one time I went to
the gym and I was and I started with box
jumps and I went to go jump on I I
started with it I took the [__] box
out I go hey guys I check into the gym
okay cool pull the pull the box out jump
on the box pull my back immediately get
off the box and just go home so I was
like in the gym for like 4 minutes and
it's so obvious that a guy hurt himself
you know like I was 38 hey guys how's it
going just have no idea in 2 minutes I'm
going to be like see you guys
so every now and then you pull your and
I use my core bro I tighten it up pulled
the pull the muscle and I go like
this I can either let this get to
me or I can
legit pretend like it didn't happen cuz
that's what I do with problems
sometimes
are you a man like me hey you got a
problem oh yeah no you
don't fixed
it
right yeah are you like me hey hey dude
oh no here comes a problem hold on a
second no do I have a problem no I
don't oops fixed
it stuff's good now
so you can do that with any problem by
the way
right you can do that with any problem
and they say that those are crazy people
I guess right like say
you're your wife dies or husband dies
and then you just pretend you go oh my
God so sad and you go you know what I
don't want to handle that actually they
didn't die and they oh that's a crazy
person right yeah but that's fine you
can be a crazy person but whoops fixed
the
problem at least you feel good who's
crazy now Pain's gone if you're that
good if you're that good right I mean we
trick ourselves all sorts of [__] you
know we trick ourselves with all sorts
of [__] like I said not I mean not all
not all the time is realness at the door
sometimes realness is at the window like
why won't you let me in and you're
looking in the mirror and you're like I
don't see me being a Fat Bob of [__] but
you you know secretly you are are but
the realness is outside and they can't
open up the
window they can't even get through the
chimney because we're convincing
ourselves that we're
handsome so if it's a problem that
you're fat blob is [__] and you can't
take that either start working
out or don't let the realness in think
about the problem and then go wait a
minute I don't have that and all of a
sudden whoops fixed
it I'm good
now like they had it down in the 40s and
50s you know remember now we don't talk
about that in his family how's the
weather right that kind of
[__] it might have been better back then
look I get it things were worse back
then but also now we got all this mental
health and everyone's a victim no matter
what it's oh tell me how you feel dude
the other day my son says I have a boo
boo I need a Band-Aid he says that's so
much dude the other day I said let me
see the boo boo it was just a little bit
pink on his on his foot and I said
you're not getting a Band-Aid you're
okay just relax look I got one too he's
like don't you want a bandaid I go no
because sometimes if you have a problem
no you
don't sometimes you may have a problem
and then no I don't oops fixed
it
so
anyway I mean I go off on such hard
tangents that I don't even remember what
I was talking about now I do
okay I'm at the gym I pull my back hey
Chris how hard how hard did you pull it
so
hard put the weight down walked over to
the water fountain I'm so hardcore I
didn't even drink water okay
I was kind of just
sauntering and I was of a purpose at the
gym but guess what I did I decided I
could either go home and fix this
problem or Not address it and fix this
problem so you know what he did
me he went
back and he finished his
[Music]
reps
slow and controlled baby did it hurt
yeah but dude I just tightened my core
up a little bit harder and did I think I
was doing more body more damage to my
body yes but was I convincing myself
that it was the right thing to do
because no matter what my body was going
to get healed even if I did keep working
out or didn't keep working out yes I did
convince myself that that and was it
true yes it was and is my back still
pulled yes but it's only 3 days later
and it'll be okay tomorrow and I'll
probably start to do some slow and
control movement movements at the gym
yes dude
uh you know hello realness cuz realness
works both
ways my body's not telling me what to do
the government's not telling me what to
do nobody's telling me what to do
but me
dude
yeah you know what I just thought
about and I love this podcast you
know but I just thought about like I had
a flash in my head just right then of me
as a
90-year-old in this room doing this and
like saying the same kind of stuff only
even
more cuz that's the problem isn't it you
just become too much too much too much
too much too much and unless you have a
reckoning or the [__] hits the fan or
you you know you lose some loved one or
your friends backstab
you you just become this crazy version
of yourself you
know and I've always said this but
that's why you know um alucino in some
movies he's just oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
and you're just like all right well no
director told him to shut it
off you got to have the fact Checkers
dude you got to have the people in the
corner that are outside ready to knock
on your
door so if I'm 90 and I'm still spouting
this [__] I hope it's at least this
[__] I hope it's this [__] I hope it's a
version of this and
not
H you got to keep your [__] loved
ones around you man you got to people
the people that know who you are like I
know yes men for people in Hollywood and
[__] and that just these Hollywood
people just become [__] [__] you
know then again it's all perception I
mean I took a picture with a [__] fan
the other day and then saw it online and
I looked like I was like in the most
miserable moment of my life and I was
like legit happy to like talk to this
person so it is what it
is let's get into some other [__] I mean
I know I'm getting some of these I mean
this episode is I like it you know don't
get me wrong I [__] think it's
hardcore but it's you know it's the
Hardcore episode but
like explore with the Bliss drift
tailored travel guidance follow Bliss
drift
Bliss drift go to my page if you want to
purchase a 10-word ad or shout out
holler. bab christalia
um who's this bivo
guy beus Brandon
I got sent this stuff the other day or
today and uh the guy
is
a you it says you know the rules who is
thisy oh man desert bivo Ed Matthews you
know the rules man no come on dude these
are the most British guys of all time
these guys couldn't look more British
with then the the bivo guy I'm assuming
bivo is the one with the goatee
because of his face and that's who would
be called
bivo Big up the S6 boys what we got one
what we not one B we have to do two but
what we got here we got brownie Brownie
and ice cream yeah yeah this is from
Georgian Dragon big up to Georg dragon
georan dragon well this let's R this out
of 10
yeah big up the brownie okay man stop
saying big up the brownie first of all
and you didn't even eat it yet you know
fumbling with it so hard and big up well
you say big up after you eat it huh got
Ed Matthews got the box
in nice oh banging that went down and
got it well come back on camera I don't
do two
t dude first of all oh my God come up
come back on camera I downed two takes
the
eagle
oh my God come in camera go on what were
you writing it out of 10 that is banging
bro that nice with your ice cream it
goes
well oh it's very curious how to get
down the
G bro hey hey hey guy hey guy laughing
it's not funny to
eat guy can't stop laughing cuz it
tastes good the dumbest guy
alive oh [__] M th bus he's going man
I'm absolutely losing
it yeah he only need twice anyway I'm
not guessing that is nice that is very
nice big up sticky is it and tend treat
treat me to a nice dessert piig up Ro
dinner cheers yeah come
[Laughter]
on I don't chew a lot that's just me is
it let's finish it off and I'll right it
oh no dude there's a minute more of this
dinner Ed Matthew's bivo I'm treating
him to a chip shop Saturday Sav chips
you know the rules big up oh dude the
first one he was wearing a Burberry
shirt and this one he's wearing a Gian
shirt it's so awesome and the other
guy's there and he's already about to
laugh and he's they got a hot dog and
[__] french fries you know don't have
to review
it yeah if you had before first time
first time what we trying this year go
on you
know sweet say dude British people will
start will start the conversation in the
middle of the conversation you know
straight up this is how a British
conversation starts oh what we're doing
out on intern it what what we doing now
then what were we deciding
something what we doing now ain't
it Jes
hey what's the thing he's doing before
he eats it for the first time I think
saying Cheers
Cheers dude this guy looks honestly like
a backstory boy with a filter on his
face bro why is it funny to
eat why is Flavor [__] gut-bustingly
hilarious banging all I've got the
ketchup pick up the ketchup you know the
rules me B what is the what are the
rules big up the ketchup you know the
rules dude imagine being a person that
says big up to
catchup you know what I'm saying
man it's
sauce ketchup don't care if you big it
up or
not you want some going all over yeah
right I'm
teaching all over I'm teaching them well
wow
dude I wonder if they're aware of what
they're saying
honestly St it's having G sa I'm still
chewing he's still chewing he's
slacking oh there a bang you know
anchoring chips sa eight8 out of 10 got
the one punch bags one punch bag with a
m sticks in this I have one each yeah
what you rate the sa though three three
you don't like sa what's stick bit of
ketchup in one mate with
that every time this guy eaty
last why is that funny that's one that's
nice that's
ni bro these guys are
incredible
okay I'm G to watch another
one dinner you know the rules big up the
come beef roast dinner beef whatever
listen we got beef uh they are so what
they are so much blankets we got a y p
in peas potatoes par Snips or so British
dude we've got peas potatoes we've got a
weird hat someone might wear and uh
we've got a guy with bad breath here we
go we know rules pick
up brussel sprouts but split up so this
so
British and a tomato for no reason just
over here in me pocket all right here we
go this you know the rules as well
Jamaican Star big up the Levi thing
actually rate this and we got none left
so I'm going have to go to the shop Levi
sort your man out send me he doesn't
even have enough you know just all the
way at the bottom should have left it
upside down anyway here we go in
it doesn't have enough
dude we getting sweet all right let's
get into this just right everything out
of 10 uh whatever that is I keep
forgetting Brussels
sprout I seasoned very well this guy's a
chipmunk very ni dude the
way he
swallows and his hair
shakes and he's like
this [__] in the back of his throat you
know right
here
very nice they cut up they're banging uh
seven out of 10 pigs in blanket sorry
Agy again you know the
rules dude the way he's swallowing
man I wish I could hang out with this
guy well this is season very well big up
the personal shift aka the dad seven out
of 10 on that uh beef well that's not
that good dude seven out of 10 is not
good
that's just absolutely mental it's
amazing wow [__] big up man this is so
[__] unbelievable let's give it a
free ah look at this this a good oh look
at this big upst still made this this a
[__] unbelievable ah let's give it a
four let's put a sauce on it make it
better ah it's so much better with the
sauce on it all right let's give it a
two let's give that with a two you put
the SAU a It's [__] amazing is it
it's a four and then you put the sauce
on it ah now it's a one that's amazing
put more sauce on it I just try and chew
this what do you mean let's just try and
do this what do you
mean just beef hanging out of his mouth
dude hey dude get rid of the mic you
know
ew just so just got out of the shower
too what dude the way
he I can spend a whole episode on this
[__]
mad Cherry mad Cherry still nice though
seven out of
10 come come on come on
dude I know you're laughing at home oh
it's [__] mad nice the way he chew
like just SW like a it's [__] too
chewy isn't it mate ah [__] s out of
10 looking well York [__] we're going to
rip a bit off this [__] looks so bad
honestly honestly honestly this plate
looks abhorent it looks so it's a
travesty it's so gross dude if you're at
your friend's house and they brought
this out you'd be like oh [__] I should
have not stayed over for
dinner standard J here seven out of 10
go bro you got to be [__] kidding
me let's get right that no another
thing I mean didn't chew that one very
seasoned very nice 7 out of 10 I think
that's sh
bro no
creativity I
mean oh parsnip oh parip let me guess
let me guess let me
guess thr it big up but listen beig up
The Hangover beef dinner overall seven
no give it an eight I'm dude everything
was a seven G an
eight seven
what big up
hangover big up the 8 out of 10 on the
dinner going to go live make just come
over catch you in the next one
Chee how is this guy real oh I love this
guy
cheese hold on let's look at oh Egypt
lunch W this guy travels how many
followers he have oh he has a million1
followers let's see what we got B oh
Burger King all right let's
see lunch you know the rules L we got a
wart we got chips it comes to a lot of
money it was de I think it's like £10
for a mill it's very close but look at
that last time I bing was in Turkey so
big up Burger King Big up the Turks big
up shopping on New Year's Day big up
your New Year we should hit a mill as
well so big up the midi let's get into
it I mean dude it's just Burger
King not
bad not bad I like the flame grilled
flame grilled cooking is good why does
he swallow like that his hair bounces so
much when he
swall not bad not bad seven out of 10
chips
bro that guy's amazing seven out of
10 well I mean you can't argue with it
right what a great guy on the internet I
love I guess you who's the other guy you
were talking about is is on
here what the [__] is this
guy this dance this is real wait what is
this guy a wacky
inflatable oh my
God who's this by hell yeah vids you
know oh
my how does he do that that's the ill
[__] ever [__] Bobby Brown who did you
put it on the
guy super oh yeah super wow here we
go here we go this guy's like the new
Salt Bay or whatever oh my God the name
dude Mr superwow Abdul
slam lude okay whatever let's see anyway
let's see what he's got
here oh the new Salt Bay dude mini
Bay wait no hold on a second I mean this
guy's just Salt Bay
only mini
Bay
oh oh
no oh no the smile
dude oh no dude fed another
man
is this guy
21 cuz he's not a
[__] he's just small as
[__] I mean did absolute
[__] if he was tall no one would
care see that's the thing about
this [__] dude super
wow is this guy is mini Bay
um let's look at another one oh man oh
God here comes another this one has a
disclaimer on it don't attempt always
got a michet dude he's got the thing
that [__] the guy uses to scar his
chest on the in the movie Predator
before the [__] Predator kills
him it's on a
knife I mean has such
OCD now he's flamming it
up is this his restaurant or is it just
some guy they hire the coffee it's
strong
right
yeah I
mean it's [__] Bak
right give me the
food okay here's me uh yeah just give it
you're you should have cooked it already
out what that was in there don't put
flames on
it oh my God doing nothing
super the
worst oh God give it to me
dude dude the other day Kristen was like
we did a thing we did I did a uh I said
something funny and she was like
um you got to write that down for the
podcast and I said okay and I didn't and
she said are you writing it down and I
was like No And she said why not and I
said cuz I don't know I I just don't
feel like it and she was like but it's
funny and I said yeah I just I don't
know and she said but you never write
stuff down for the podcast and I said no
sometimes I do and I don't know I don't
think it wants to I don't I don't want
to write that down right now I guess and
she she's like but you're going to
forget it and I said can I be honest
with you and she said yeah I said I
don't want to talk about that on the
podcast she says you don't and I said
yeah she said why I said CU I don't
think it's that
funny is that
wild I think that's
wild I need to be more honest like that
I didn't want to and that's okay right
[__] it's and here it is I lasted 46
minutes I'm sweating my my balls off
here we go taking the shirt off taking
the shirt off show them my tattoos what
anyone know what that's from leave it in
the comments take my shirt I show them
my
tattoos um there we go shirt's too small
but he's beefed out so it's
okay
um oh
god oh I sweat out I feel so much better
dude I'm [__] pretty cool with my
[__] tattoos I need to get more
tattoos dude I need to get more
tattoos what are we doing
here it's award season I saw um I don't
watch it I you know what awards
dude there shouldn't be Awards
man who cares who the best whatever was
UN unless it's no you know what there
shouldn't be Awards and I'll tell you
why because even when it's based
off
of is the right word meritocracy
you already know who won like it's the
best guy best one
whatever you already know who won like
if the best skier you know who won they
were the quickest or the or did all the
moves right it's not left to
interpretation so you should either not
have Awards because it's left to
interpretation which is [__] because
we all know that the Oscars and
everything like that is is just a a
bunch of handshaking [__]
together picking what they want or
or it's just based off of who actually
won and you don't need an award because
you already know you
won oh I ran the fastest here's your
award don't need it ran the fastest know
that and everyone else knows that that's
my award why do I need a physical thing
to put on my
mantle so it's like just be gone with
the
awards and then they got because they
got Golden Globes they got Emmys they
got critic's choice they got the SAG
Awards they got it's like dude make at
least make one that is the only
one and then you had the critic choice
choice awards and then Chelsea
Handler put a jab to Joe koi which was
[__] [__] that's so like they
went out together you know and then she
just pulls that jab afterwards like oh
yeah and I'd like to thank my writers on
that one cuz they wrote that one and
it's just like that was kind of whack
you did
that
not classy I guess but I don't know
comedy isn't really it's like people
don't want to be classy at all period
because they want to
just get the clicks you know what I'm
saying it's all about relevance like
after this R Cat Williams [__] the guy's
got the highest selling [__] now Tour
all of his stuff is back on the
algorithm and everything it's crazy all
because he just talks [__] A bunch about
a bunch of people and like we're we're I
hate when people say this but like where
I come from and I don't mean like
physically and geologically but like in
my mind State like unloading the clip on
a bunch of [__] and like doing
it just to get Clips is is it's so
whack to
me because it's
like you do [__] up [__] too you
know I don't
know dude how funny was it that Cory hul
said the thing about stealing jokes was
hilarious oh it was so funny dude let's
see if I can look it up Cory hle
come God this guy makes me
laugh here wait hold on this is so
funny is this it how long is it how long
is it it need to be God this is funny
yeah it's a minute long should be it God
damn it how am I not signed in always
not signed in all right here we go but
dude this is so funny everything you
said Jay yes like what somebody on here
said it's not fair more than no play
it the high why do this happen but I
don't hold on you got you guys got to
hear this it's so
funny
YouTube actually I just have it on my
phone let me just play
it somebody sent it to
me ah the comedy community you
know this is funny
though where is it
just here we go here we go here we go
glad that cat went on Club sh sh where a
lot of [__] got to explain [__]
if you stole jokes you stole jokes
listen 90% of comedians steal jokes cat
stole JB smooth joke and did it on his
special it's the joke with the music too
many Comics know what I'm saying is
straight I just stole a joke before this
the truth I stole a [__] from Columbus
Ohio joke the [__] name was Stephen G
people basically borrow and they kind of
like no it's not borrowing I stole his
joke I just stuck one day and I remember
his joke and I did it and they paid me
$500 so Stephen G get up with me homie
I'm going give you 500 plus interest I
swear this the truth I took a [__] joke
before we can't have a [__] just
telling on everybody if you ain't F to
stand on who you are if you a [__] who
telling on [__] and putting everybody
else [__] out there and you be doing the
same [__] ain't nobody going to respect
you they going to be like oh hell no
[__] you everybody you be doing that
[__] you get what I'm saying so that's
what I'm trying to say if you really
going to be the shepherd of men we going
to step back and respect you cuz you
polarizing my [__] [__] love Cat
Williams he a little [__] all them
little [__] people like him my [__]
cat listen you can stand up and be
something that people really
[__] be like
okay but see you also got to remember us
[__] in the comedy streets I'm glad
that cat went on Club sh that's funny
bro that made me
laugh CU it make because it's like
dude wow that made me
laugh look at there here we go
misconnections here let's do some
misconnections it's been a long time
since I did
misconnections here's a hinge connection
it says hinge connection Los Angeles
looking for someone down to twirl and do
tricks with with I mean so weird
preferably named Amanda would love to
scheme and get up to hij jinkx with you
why is his name got to be [__] Amanda
dude kinks are crazy weird huh like you
just and if and if your name's Amanda
forget
it here's another one missing my biker
buddy kovina wow that sentence makes
complete sense all of it chubby guy used
to go down on my biker friend after his
rides looking for
newbody chubby guy used to go down on my
biker friend after his rides
wow most you know if you're the the
other guy and you're gay that's pretty
cool I guess for you you know I'm g go
for a ride get
sucked I'm go for a ride and get all
sweaty where my balls are and then get
sucked here we go uh let's watch another
one let's watch Monday Night Football
Gardina
42-year-old male missing my friend who
would just kick back and watch football
with me I have Refreshments sad
nonsexual
dude s sad um here's another one looking
for a lady to eat out ride offered I
mean LA to San Francisco
Jesus you come over to me I come over to
you or we can do it in my car single
white male is here in good
shape what's the ride LA to SF is crazy
that's 5 hours of what pull what's
longer than that cuz you're pulling over
to do some munchin you
know what do you think when we hit svang
you want to do some
munchin ladies here's another one
Pasadena does your secret garden I love
when they miss when they leave a word
out by mistake dude here it says does
your secret garden tending to ciot does
you yo proofread you know especially if
it's sex talk does your secret garden
need tending to I'd love to help be your
personal
Gardener
absolute
um disgusting
this the depravity you
know guys huh you know you know what I
mean
guys you put them in the in a just a
certain type of mood in a certain type
of situation and they're just all in you
know like a woman has to be in the mood
for sex a guy doesn't a guy could just
be like doing something else not in the
mood and can be convinced in like five
seconds wow it's got to be like that
otherwise there wouldn't be 8 billion
people in the world all good all right
well that's it um
thanks for listening uh go to our
patreon patreon.com christalia it really
helps us out with the PO with the uh
podcast and we love you you're the
reason the patreon members are the
reason you guys are the reason that uh
this podcast is Alive and Well
appreciate you um and I'll be in uh Brea
and Phoenix next and Albuquerque and El
Paso go watch my special grow or die
christ.com appreciate
[Music]
you fuing
youu
[__]
[Music]